good morning to you it's seven o'clock
this is sky news breakfast now with the
eyes of the world on the uk for cop26
it's really not a good time for the sort
of headlines facing the prime minister
this morning there are accusations of
chaos in number 10 over the owen
patterson lobbying case with some
conservative mps questioning boris
johnson's leadership we'll talk to the
education secretary nadim zahawi shortly
and later in the program we'll hear from
labour's shadow scotland secretary ian
murray
plus what scouts across the world are
doing to help combat climate change
we'll talk to the uk's chief scout and
adventurer bear grylls this morning
ben let's live
[Music]
a new song full remembrance we'll speak
to the composer jamie lonsdale at 9 45
it is friday the 5th of november
i've never felt more unsafe on set in a
uk exclusive interview a senior member
on the alec baldwin film rust tells sky
news the fatal shooting of a
cinematographer could have been
prevented
i've never felt i was more in danger of
dying on the set or on the drive home
because i was exhausted
taking climate change to the classroom
new plans for children to be taught
about protecting the planet
devastating delays the impact of the
pandemic on couples being made to wait
for ivf treatment
shall we
shall we fly shall we die
[Applause]
a total one-off tribute to the dancer
and entertainer lionel blair who's died
at the age of 92.
the weather today dry but cloudy for
most of us the weekend should be a
little bit milder
[Music]
morning to you a senior crew member on
the film rust has told sky news he never
felt as close to death as he did on the
set in the days before helena hutchins
was killed lane looper was a lead camera
operator but resigned the day before the
cinematographer was shot dead with a
live bullet fired by alec baldwin in a
uk exclusive interview looper says
hutchins death was absolutely
preventable
he's been speaking to our u.s
correspondent martha kelner
i've never felt more unsafe
on set
or offset you know
i have never been i've never felt i was
more in danger of dying on the set or on
the drive home because i was exhausted
lane looper was the head of the camera
department on rust working alongside
cinematographer helena hutchins she was
shot dead by the film's star alec
baldwin
lane is speaking out now because he says
his friend's death was caused by cutting
costs and cutting corners
this set was unsafe
simply because they didn't have the
wherewithal to you know follow you know
safety rules that we have in this
industry that we've been following for
decades do you believe that helena's
death was preventable absolutely
absolutely
looper resigned from the film on safety
grounds the day before hutchins death
sky news has seen a copy of the letter
he sent to a production manager he warns
of two accidental firearms discharges
and says the filming of gunfights was
played very fast and loose how will you
remember helena for people who didn't
know her what what was she like she was
approachable she was talented
um she was going places we became
friends really quick and uh
yeah it just hurts to lose a loser
friend like that
in a statement the producers of rust
said mr lupa's allegations around budget
and safety are patently false
safety is always the number one priority
in our films and it's truly awful to see
someone using this tragedy for personal
gain
the police investigation into helena
hutchins death is ongoing
one of the central questions they're
considering is why exactly live
ammunition was on a film set at all
this is a typical pistol that would be
used in a western it's been musing two
to douglas stewart he was one of the
actors on rust seen here with leading
lady francis fisher he had a positive
experience on set the master would open
up the cartridge here but he's now
joining calls for real guns to be banned
on films
for there to be a live round in a gun
handed to an actor
unconscionable unbelievable
everybody in my acting community we were
stunned just
couldn't believe it happened
and still can't
those who worked with helena hutchins
say she would have become one of
hollywood's leading cinematographers
they now hope her legacy can be that of
safest sets for cast and crew a legacy
which means a similar tragedy cannot
happen again martha kellner sky news new
mexico
well still to come for you this morning
as thousands of young people are
expected to march through glasgow today
i'm going to be talking to two climate
activists about the role that young
people play
in protecting the planet
also heading to the city today are a
group of mothers from around the world
who want leaders to stop financing
fossil fuel projects for the sake of
their children's health i'm going to be
talking to one of them at about a
quarter to eight
andy secretary scotland ian murray will
be live on the programme at five past
eight this morning
now boris johnson may want attention to
be focused on the efforts to tackle
climate change at the cop 26 summit but
he's having to deal with the very
unhappy atmosphere at westminster and
the fallout from the owen patterson rail
let's talk to the education secretary
nadim zahawi he's at the cop 26 summit
in glasgow it's good to see you this
morning i mean when it comes to this
owen patterson issue
with hindsight
do you think
that this shouldn't have been pursued
that the the suspension should have just
been left
to continue
well i think it's important uh to
remember that the prime minister and in
your opening remarks you talked about
today's summit and youth and
uh of course
climate is incredibly important and it's
youth and education day here in glasgow
but the prime minister's always been
very clear that your paid lobbying is
not allowed
the
i think the mistake
which to your point to your question is
the conflation of creating a fairer
system with the right of appeal
for parliamentarians
to be able to put forward
effectively you know an appeal process
and then conflating that with a
particular case of owen patterson was a
mistake and i think the leader of the
house jacob rees-mogg came to the house
yesterday upon reflection yes it was a
mistake and i think it was right to come
back very quickly to the house and say
look we need to separate those two
things out we should work on a
cross-party basis to create a fairer
system i think that's a good thing and
my appeal to my fellow parliamentarians
from all parties is let's come together
and create a better system with the
right of appeal and it was right to
separate the two things out that was the
mistake and i think it was right to
reflect and return to parliament and
correct that
do you accept then that owen patterson
did something wrong
well i think look the uh commissioner
had investigated and had come back on
the
investigation around what owen patterson
was doing in terms of
his work for two companies
that is as i said to you the prime
minister has always been clear that that
paid lobbying is wrong
and we need to separate those two things
out as i say
the thing to focus on is not this
particular case but to focus on creating
a fairer system with the right of appeal
for all parliamentarians
but are you voted for this for this
change didn't you i mean i mean
obviously there was there was the the
whip involved in this but we know an
awful lot of your your uh colleagues on
the back benches were really really
uncomfortable with this
why did you feel the need to vote for it
well again i would say to your viewers
that i take collective responsibility
i'm a secretary of state
a cabinet member in this government and
we voted
because i thought actually improving the
system and introducing a right of appeal
as you would have in many sectors of the
economy in many professions people have
a right of appeal i think your viewers
would understand there's a fairness
argument here but upon reflection i do
think it's a mistake to have conflated
that with a specific
issue around the investigation into owen
patterson and i think it was right that
we reflected on that and the leader of
the house came back to the house
yesterday and we basically said
as much that it was a mistake and we
need to separate those things out and i
hope we'll be able to return with
proposals and have a cross-party
agreement as to how we improve the
system to introduce a right of appeal
into it
i mean
how much of this
change of hard and this 19-hour later
u-turn from number 10 on this you say it
was because you didn't want to conflate
the issues but how much of that was
driven by the fact that
mr patterson told our deputy political
editor he'd do it again
well i don't want to comment on uh
anything that um you know
owen patterson said on interviews
other than to say the prime minister
made a very clear statement um
recognizing owen patterson's 24 years of
service
recognizing uh that let's not forget you
know there is a family here that have
just lost a mother and a wife um who he
and his family were devoted to and
there's a bit you need a bit of
compassion in our hearts as well uh but
in saying that the mistake that i think
we want to correct is to separate that
out and this particular case from what i
think is the right thing to do and the
fair thing and if a parliament to
concentrate on is to get our appeals
process in place for all
parliamentarians in the future
well i mean mr patterson wants some
compassion doesn't he when he's resigned
he said he stepped down to escape the
cruel world of politics i mean a cruel
world that along with his lobbying it
was netting him about 200 or very nearly
200 grand a year i don't think the
public's gonna
be overly sympathetic are they and you
need to bear that in mind
well i think the the the public will
make their own judgment uh on this um
all i would say
is that um
it's worth remembering that there is a
family here concerned who've just lost
a mother um there are children and of
course owen himself
but the public will make up their own
mind on this i think the priority has to
be now for us and i hope i can appeal to
my colleagues across the house let's
shed our political differences aside
let's not play politics with this let's
get the system right because the system
does need a right of appeal and that's
the fairest thing to do and that's what
i think andrea alexander was trying to
achieve with her amendment
now that didn't work i think it was
right for us to come back to parliament
and for the leader of the house say look
we think we made a mistake by conflating
the two things uh in one and i think now
is the time to come together and just
deal with the the process uh to which we
you know we hold ourselves to account
forgive me though i mean this has been
an absolute shambles in terms of
management hasn't it from from number 10
down i mean even with i mean one of your
colleagues matt shawley saying on
twitter even if voters forget this
shambles tory mps won't scores of them
held their nose had arms twisted faced
abuse online and in post bags and now
boris johnson has made them look like
idiots they'll remember that the next
time there's a
rebellion well as i say look the
important thing is for all
parliamentarians on all sides now to
focus on what is truly material what is
material is and i've spoken to uh
the speaker of the house and i think he
agrees with me on this what's material
is to maintain confidence in the
processes and the system that we have in
place and improve it if we can through a
right of appeal that's something that's
worth working on that's something that's
worth putting energy into
rather than you know putting
i'd rather focus on that than than waste
my my energy and time on on on sort of
your tit for tat or being angry
okay what what about apologizing then to
to someone like catherine stone um
because i mean there are questions as to
whether the conservative party has made
her position untenable through no fault
of her own actually but quasi-cuatang
said yesterday she should just she she
now needs to decide her position
i mean for what for doing her job
well first of all i think it's important
to
remind
all uh
parliamentarians and of course your
viewers the country at large that
catherine stone uh the commissioner
works for the house um
for parliament for the legislature and i
think it's only right that i echo uh you
know the words of the speaker by saying
actually uh it is up to the house um how
uh uh
the the the commissioner and the
procedures actually are delivered and i
think that's the important thing to
remember and this that's what i would i
would leave it i was hoping we were also
going to talk about youth and education
uh day-to-day at cop 26 but you know
happy to continue talking about the
procedures of parliament if that's what
you look like well yeah we will talk
about the youth in just a second but but
one final point on this then there is an
acceptance is there from what you say
that quasi quartet did actually speak
out of turn yesterday
well
as i say it's important that uh to
remember and i don't think kwazii was
saying anything different that actually
katherine was saying the commissioner
has a responsibility to the legislature
to the house of commons and the speaker
was absolutely right in reminding all of
us
that that is
the correct thing to do um
and look
i'm happy uh to continue uh talking
about this but i hope we can also talk
about what i'm launching today which is
uh our sustainability and climate change
strategy which will i hope support
teachers to deliver
you know evidence-led
education through stem science subjects
through geography and of course
through citizenship
to our students including the primary
model science curriculum uh primary
school as well and of course we're
launching a a a national education park
if you take all our schools nurseries
colleges and and universities they're
about you know
the size of two birmingham cities
of parkland and land that we think we
can create a sort of a virtual coming
together of all of that uh parkland to
to teach
young people about biodiversity about
spatial planning about
geospatial mapping all these things are
incredibly exciting and it's worth just
you know i hope leaning into youth and
and and
climate day to day well it's interesting
though isn't it because i mean i i don't
think anyone's going to criticize a move
to to provide more education for young
people when it comes to to climate but i
mean the reality is at the moment it's
young people who are teaching us
well i think one you're absolutely right
and uh
my nine-year-old mia on monday came back
from school said dad you better be going
to this meeting in glasgow i said me i'm
absolutely going it's a summit and it's
bringing together over 190 uh
world leaders
uh together because we really have to
continue to try and deliver on on you
know on the 1.5
commitment
and she was happy that i'm here and my
team is leading in i've got ministerial
colleagues from the department of
education
tomorrow forgive forgive me for jumping
in but she she's not there today 50 000
young people are marching on cop 26
today i mean do you support young people
missing school to attend a march about
climate change
well no actually because i'd rather they
they march on saturday and sunday so the
the summit is here for at least two
weekends and what i would urge young
people is not to miss school not to miss
class we don't want to get into a
situation where teachers and head
teachers are having to actually find and
issue fines
for missing education
i'd rather they
they make their point on saturday and
sunday and then
i would absolutely support them to do
that this weekend and the weekend after
that is the way to do it that is the way
to continue
to take the message to world leaders and
by the way the education part of this
that i've just described to you
including a climate leaders awards which
we're going to be working with the
princess trust and the duke of edinburgh
awards to create these you know really i
hope what will be you know world leading
awards that young people
can also use in in in sort of later in
life as they sort of hopefully go
through their career paths um will allow
them not just to protest but also to
think about their own career in science
and technology and innovation there's so
much to do here whether it be on fusion
or offshore wind or solar or some of the
new hydrogen technologies that are
coming through that all comes through
education so i want to be able to i hope
inspire young minds
on a saturday or sunday if they are here
um to say look you engage with us on
this because it's important that you are
part of the solution as well as part of
the pressure on world leaders
minister good to talk to you thank you
let's see thank you
now india is the world's third largest
polluter but despite the country's prime
minister telling the cop 26 summit it
was ready to become a climate action
champion
it has an emergency on its own shoreline
as katarina vitozi reports a million
people are at risk of rising sea levels
in the indian
sundarbans a collection of low-lying
islands of the country's east coast
on this island few places feel safe
goromara was hit by a cyclone six months
ago
it left many with nothing
temporary shelters are now permanent
homes
so is this
this is where you're living at the
moment
sanawara's family lost everything
this shack now houses five people
second of all
here there is already no line between
land and water few believe this island
will be habitable by 2070 the year india
the world's third largest polluter says
it'll finally be net zero
even now salt water from the rising sea
is poisoning fresh water reserves
we've got this meter here we're going to
take a measurement of the salt content
in this pond and it feeds into all the
paddies around here and
theoretically it's the end of the
monsoon season so this should be the
freshest this water is ever going to be
let's take a look but yeah even then
it's measuring
0.2
percent so that means not only is this
water still too salty
for people to grow rice in but it's also
unsafe to drink
foreign
there are now desperate attempts to try
and save what's left to make the island
more resistant to intensifying cyclones
but many families have already left to a
nearby bigger island
arrived here from guramara eight years
ago with nothing
but now this home like every other
across the indian sunderbans is at risk
there are already calls for a planned
retreat
one million people could be displaced
forced from their homes
from these islands that are slowly but
surely disappearing
catering over totsi sky news in the
indian sunderbans
we can see katarina's documentary
climate crisis life on the front line
tonight at nine o'clock
on sky news
well here's a look at the climate change
as it's happening for you today you can
see the estimated temperature change
compared to pre-industrial levels this
is now above 1.2 degrees under that what
we think is the carbon dioxide emissions
most of this coming from burning fossil
fuels
and that continues to rise and of course
feeding the temperature change on the
right you can see the real-time power
mix
this data comes from the national grid
and it illustrates the sources of our
electricity generation at this moment in
time the renewables wind solar and
hydroelectric
well for uninterrupted coverage of the
summit including special guests and
analysis you can watch sky news climate
live on channel 525 and sky glass
channel 505.
let's have a look at the uk's latest
covered numbers for you today and 37
269 new infections have been recorded in
the last 24 hours
there have been
214 more deaths that's the third day
running that now the number has been
above 200. it brings a total number of
deaths within 28 days of a positive test
to 141
395.
the new campaign has been launched to
raise awareness of how simple
ventilation can help reduce the risk of
catching covid19 this winter a short
film shows how opening a window for just
10 minutes can significantly reduce the
levels of the virus in the air while
socializing
now hundreds of people waiting for ivf
treatment have spoken of the devastating
delays they face because of the pandemic
for some couples the hold-ups could mean
the difference between being able to
have a child or not
and many have been able to get
counselling
melena
it took 11 rounds of ivf for amber to
conceive her son
when she and her husband tried to give
him a sibling kovitch shut all
treatments down
putting her dreams of expanding her
family in peril
for me waiting eight months i was
already 37 and when you're third you
know when you're 37 eight months is a
long time in fertility and now we're at
a year and a half down the line and i'm
a year and a half older more than that
now
and we're still not anywhere um so i
think it's that it's the time pressure
that you'd have in your late 30s that
really kind of added to the to the
stress and the worry
a survey by the charity fertility
network uk found that kovid delayed ivf
treatment for more than half of the
respondents and that lost time experts
say can make a difference between being
able to have a baby or not
it does cause a lot of stress
particularly for women who are older and
who have reduced egg reserve
the time is of the essence and that puts
additional stress on them because they
are concerned about their egg reserve
going down
and their chances of having a baby with
their own eggs
when treatment resumed for lauren and
nick coveted protocols meant they
couldn't see a nurse to show them how to
prepare medication and were given a
booklet with instructions instead
it was just so hard to try and
just read that without going having a
nurse to go through and then go right
yeah this is how you do it
did you have any guidance as to how to
do things properly
we couldn't ask any questions at all
really there were no one to show us no
there's nobody to show us nobody to tell
us what to do nobody said reassure us
even
that we were doing the right thing
lauren got pregnant after three attempts
but for many couples delays meant
diminishing chances of having a much
wanted child
milena veselinovich sky news
now the former england captain michael
vaughan has strongly denied an
allegation of racism against azeem rafiq
and two other asian players at the
yorkshire county cricket club
his comments follow an internal
investigation which found azeem rafiq
face racial harassment and bullying
while playing there writing in the
telegraph this morning michael vaughan
said rafiq had accused him of saying
there are too many of you lot to three
asian players
the former england captain said i
completely and categorically deny that i
ever said those words vaughan added i
have nothing to hide the eulog comment
never happened
anyone trying to recollect words said 10
years ago will be fallible but
i'm adamant those words were not used
prince andrews bid to have a u.s sex
abuse civil lawsuit thrown out of court
will be heard before a judge in january
next year the case being brought by
virginia gaffrey is expected to go to
trial towards the end of next year
providing it's not settled or dismissed
before then
a 21 year old man has been charged after
admitting seven counts of sending
offensive messages on twitter which was
sent to the police by chelsea football
club their one tweet nathan black said
spurs are on their way to auschwitz
attributes are being paid to the dancer
and entertainer lionel blair who's died
at the age of 92.
shall we well shall we fly shall we die
[Music]
well his career spanned eight decades
including appearances and that as an
actor and tap dancer scene in this
dance-off against sammy davies jr this
was at the 1961 royal variety
performance but he is of course
best known for being team captain on the
tv game show
give us a clue
but the singer michael ball called him a
funny kind
generous compassionate and gifted man so
sad for his family and for our business
a total one-off
bonnie langford said dear lionel
privileged to have been your dance
partner
and the actor sanjeev bhaskar said i
love the fact he'd always pepper every
conversation with a bit of a tap dance
every single time
and it was glorious
he was on the show with me and jillian
oh three or four years ago now and he
was an absolute
gent a real charm it was a privilege
to meet him
now let's have a look at weather for you
and
well it's looking really dry before more
unsettled conditions arrive tomorrow but
it will be milder over the weekend
chilly out there with a widespread frost
against england and wales especially in
the south
cloud in the north and west will become
more extensive through the morning but
southeast england will hold on to the
sunshine most places dry but the west
will see some light rain or drizzle
now if you're an original abba fan
you've been waiting 40 years for today
it's the release of the new studio album
called voyage the first since the 1981
album the visitors and this is the
trailer for the band's upcoming voyage
concert and here we're showing
previously unseen footage of the avatars
in action these incredible um
virtual sort of bodies they've been
given it's a short clip they're not
giving much away but probably just
enough to whet your appetite for the
shows which start in may and by which
time we should know all the socks on the
album
word for word hopefully
uh still to come on sky news breakfast
for you this morning i'm going to be
talking to two youth climate activists
about cop 26 and the fridays for future
demonstrations that have been taking
place globally
[Music]
now the education secretary has admitted
the government made a mistake over the
way it's handled the case of owen
patterson in the house of commons
speaking to me earlier nadim zahar we
said creating a system of appeal for
suspended mps should not have been
conflated with the case of allegations
about lobbying by mr patterson
upon reflection yes it was a mistake and
i think it was right to come back very
quickly to the house and say look we
need to separate those two things out we
should work on a cross-party basis to
create a fairer system i think that's a
good thing and my appeal to my fellow
parliamentarians from all parties is
let's come together and create a better
system with the right of appeal and it
was right to separate the two things out
that was the mistake and i think it was
right to reflect and return to
parliament and correct that
let's talk to our political
correspondent rob powell i mean he used
quite careful language there yeah
delicately put as ever but i think
that's probably as close as you're going
to get uh to someone in government
publicly admitting what an utter dog's
breakfast number ten's handling of this
has been over the last um 48 hours nadim
zahari saying it was a mistake to
conflate the issues also as well i think
detected a little bit of frustration
with the business secretary quasi
quatering who of course was in glasgow
yesterday speaking to k burley and
suggested that the standards
commissioner catherine stone who
conducted that investigation um into
owen paterson kwasi kwateng suggested
essentially that she may well be out of
a job because they're reforming the
system the dean zahawi said that he
would remind all parliamentarians that
katherine stone works for the house and
would echo what the speaker said
yesterday when the speaker ticked off
quasi quarten um as well so again
delicately put but i think we can read
into that that people were not happy
with what quasi quartens said yesterday
in terms of where this all leaves us
well i think the government have soaked
up quite a lot of political damage on
this you can see that a poll
taken overnight after this all came out
showed that it's eaten into their lead
against labour we'll also get a
by-election in north shropshire as well
and early talks have already started
between the opposition parties about
potentially fielding one anti-sleaze
candidate that could be really the only
chance of overturning the conservative
majority there i think a word of caution
these unity candidates sound good on
paper but often when it comes out to
working out the practicalities it's a
lot more tricky okay rob for now thank
you
now saving the planet is to become part
of the school curriculum
let's join ender brady is at a school in
west london for us this morning ender
yeah morning stephen we're at arc
burlington danes academy here in west
london let's bring in head teacher
sophie velakot sophie how much of your
daily teaching life here or school life
is climate change in the environment
it's really important to our school and
it's really important to our people so
we have some of the work that we do is
part of the national curriculum and then
there's other things that we do that
support that through our non-examined
curriculum and some other programs such
as earth warriors which we do in
addition to our normal lessons and
you've signed up to be an eco school
you've just won your first green flag
what does that entail yeah absolutely we
signed up in autumn and have been
working all together through the program
we have one particular teacher who leads
on this and she's set up an eco
committee which is all about championing
the pupil voice through the process and
they make decisions around what they can
do to improve their school tell me how
aware say are primary school-aged
children of someone like greta tonborg
for example
especially at the moment one of our year
six cohorts are doing a unit on global
challenges and we've tied it this in
really really smoothly i think with cop
26 and with greta's role in that for the
children to have a role model who is
young relatable to them and they can
feel like they can be the change makers
is both important to us as a school but
especially because it's part of our
vision our vision is to to develop
little humans to be the change makers of
the future so really climate change the
environment it's all stitched into the
curriculum very much absolutely and i
don't think the children would feel like
it's an add-on i think they would feel
that it's part of everything they do at
school sophie velikov head teacher here
thanks for having us we're here
throughout the day stephen and it's
interesting the children in year six
will be having a debate later on where
they pretend to be
world leaders at cop26 and there will be
a discussion and interviews and press
conferences and we'll be filming all of
it
yeah i wonder if they come up with some
better answers than the actual world
leaders will at the end of all of this
ender thank you we'll catch up with you
later
well as the focus of cop 26 turns to
youth and public empowerment thousands
of young climate activists are expected
to attend a march in glasgow some will
miss school part of the fridays for
future movement which sees students go
on strike from school to take action
against climate change
well let's talk to two climate activists
dominique lasota and ashley lashley and
i know dominica you're
um part of of the uh the friday action
how important is it for you to get out
and make your voice heard
mean it was absolutely crucial at this
point because we see that the
governments have not been treating us
seriously since the beginning of this
conference you know when we hear boris
johnson coming in and giving us a nice
speech but actually at the same time not
stopping the combo oil field you see
that the ambition the adequacy and the
severity of this crisis of treating this
crisis is missing among the people in
power and so we have to march in a way
because we see that there's no one out
there who treats our lives seriously at
this point but at the same time i think
that you know we got so used to those
marches on friday we got so used to
young people having to go out of school
and and march on the streets but we
shouldn't get used to it they shouldn't
be there they should be safe and they
should be safe because of political
action that should have been taken by
the government but it's not so let's not
normalize it let's you know bring out
the anger because i feel so much anger
and hopelessness seeing how the club 26
has been going so far
i mean do you do you go along with that
ashley do you think that there is an
element of betrayal from our our leaders
at the moment
yeah i can totally agree
um right now your voices are
significantly essential to bring about
societal change within our different
societies globally and the time is not
if governments really want to build a
just and fair future for all that they
must take our views into consideration
when developing their policies and for
right now here at cloud 26 we are not
included
well i was given the opportunity to join
my barbados delegation but hearing lots
of young persons speak to the injustices
that they're seeing here at cop26 i
really believe that more youth
involvement should be here at cloud 26.
do you not think though dominica that
although the the
the movement that the change may not be
fast enough for what you would like do
you not think that significant steps
are being taken
honestly we have been talking so much
about the climate crisis through the
past three years as this wave of climate
activism and human people has been you
know gathering incredible force so
definitely climate crisis is a topic and
it is one of the priorities but if
behind this we don't see concrete action
and we see for instance this empty coal
agreement that was announced yesterday
while the polish government for instance
which is which is my government and
still found a way to trick it and not
actually commit to a coal facade by 2030
we see that there's still so much to do
while the climate crisis is accelerating
at a significant significant pace and
when it comes to hearing those young
voices i think there is a lot of youth
watching actually at cop happening you
know we see young people being invited
to panels we see young people being
praised and and you know thanked for
for their action but this is in a way
you know just another method for the
people in power to say okay you know we
listen to them we say we listen to them
but we don't change and this must change
because we are just you know nine years
uh behind um the deadline actually that
will determine how our society global
society will look for forever actually
i mean it's interesting you you say that
you know they listen but but then don't
do a lot about it i mean you formed
actually the the hay group healthy and
environment friendly youth in barbados i
mean how how important is it then if you
don't feel you're being listened to how
important is it to in effect take
matters into your own hands and try and
dictate your own future
no it is very important and that is one
of the main reasons why i started the
hay campaign because coming from a
country like barbados being in
a small island developing state where
severely susceptible and vulnerable to
the impact that climate change is having
on our lives although our government has
set ambitious targets developed nations
also need to set ambitious targets and
the main reason behind the establishment
of the hey campaign is because
as young persons we need to stand up for
something
and every day in barbados we're
witnessing the dramatic changes to our
environment so youth coming together
youth from the care being connected to
those across the world to build bridges
that are inclusive is important in
today's decade because we really need to
see that change from a society
perspective to be more inclusive
vulnerable groupings recently unicef
launched a report that states that 100
that one billion children worldwide are
being affected by climate change and
right now climate change is a civil
rights crisis so i love to see young
people rising up to taking action
because at the end of the day our lives
depend on the actions in which our
government stay today
ashley dominica really good to talk to
both of you today thank you
well this is sky news breakfast let's
get a look at all the sport for you this
morning for jackie
chase the pack achieve your goals and
unlock rewards live life with vitality
and zwift the app that makes indoor
cycling fun this sports bulletin is
brought to you by vitality and zwift
it's no surprise to anyone you love the
club when did that start you in
liverpool when i was in chelsea then i
came here
the atmosphere was unbelievable then i
said like wow
i want to play here one day
and that's why when i was in rome and
there is talk between the clubs and i
was like i will go there i would love to
play there
the atmosphere is unbelievable
i want to come back to you to england to
to prove people wrong and i didn't have
my chance there chelsea so i will go
back for sure so i came back i also when
i was young i was playing with liverpool
in playstation so it's like there is
kind of emotional between us or between
me and the club so i just like i'm gonna
go so with that in mind then the fact
that it was a bit of a dream to come
here everything you've achieved how much
longer
do you see yourself in the role of
liverpool you know it's a
you know it's a topic at the moment this
is not depend of me but if you ask me i
would love to stay until last day if my
football but
i can't say much about that not in my
hand okay can i ask you what it does
depend on
then it depends on what the club want
not depend on me at the moment i can't
see myself ever play against liverpool
that will make me sad
and
it's it's hard it's hard i don't want to
talk
about it but it's it it would make me
really sad if i
at the moment i don't see myself playing
with liverpool but let's see what will
happen in the future what's left for you
you've now been playing here in the
premier league african player of the
year you've won the champions league
you've won the premier league 30 next
year
yeah
i think what more can you do
i can do a lot i still that's why i'm
always focusing the game just to show
some people that i can play
and top level for many many years i
think i'm in the top shape as well can't
play until 38 39 i'm not worried about
that 39 yeah
until my like my kids say hey come play
with us leader for that would be nice do
you think can top players go live life
with vitality and zwift the app that
makes indoor cycling fun
[Music]
jackie thank you still to come on sky
news breakfast the mothers heading to
cop26 to put an end to images like this
they want fossil fuels to be banned
[Music]
i'm greg milam sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
i've seen the dark side of america
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
well there's a real sense now that
people are beginning to expect that this
whole airlift is coming to an end and
they're really really desperate
we saw snatchbox going in grabbing
people and putting them into trucks
[Music]
you either live and recover
or you die
okay so that's like a wall that's the
war yeah
we help you understand the world with us
over the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
[Music]
to take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
they were convinced the united states
[Music]
the enormous explosion has just come
down i think the monsters just landed in
between us
the information on this could bring down
the entire network not just in iraq and
syria but across the world
[Music]
[Applause]
could prove it withdrawn it's so so hot
[Music]
does anyone know which particular parts
of your body can be damaged by air
pollution
[Music]
friday will start chilly with a fairly
widespread frost across england and
wales during the morning cloud will
become more extensive giving patchy
light rain in the north and west but the
southeast will hold on to the sunshine
for most it won't be quite as cold as
recently
the afternoon will be similar but cloud
will extend into the southeast of
england
air pollution levels are expected to
stay low overall but light winds may
allow isolated pockets of moderate
levels to develop near diwali or early
bonfire night celebrations
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
now she's a woman who's played the most
famous and most glamorous characters in
soap history alexis colby in dynasty of
course award a classic now in her late
80s believe it or not
joan collins is of course just as
glamorous and just as outspoken having
published an uncensored memoir
our arts and entertainment correspondent
katie spencer caught up with her
from starting out during hollywood's
golden age through to playing one of the
80s most iconic tv characters dame joan
collins's new memoir starts after
dynasty has ended you don't mince your
words in this book i never mince my
words
i had this tiny tape recorder and i used
to use it when i was working on dynasty
to learn my lines i it just gave me
total freedom and i never ever ever
thought it would be published what we
hear through your voice in this we don't
hear from modern celebrities at all
because of council culture would you say
that you're you're anti-woke that you
sort of don't really care what people
think i really don't care that much what
people think of course i do up to a
certain
amount but i think that um people are
caring too much about having their
opinions
and not being able to say what they
think you can't have debates you can't
throw opinions about what you think
about this particular thing statues
being taken down for example you can't
have that argument with somebody who
wants statues taken down of people
um who they are just
belligerent almost i know well that's my
experience you talk about boris johnson
in there it's a brilliant description
that you have saying he looks like he
brushes his hair with an egg beater
i mean do you think he's got any better
does carrie need to have a word have you
seen his child his child's hair is even
more wild than than his i like boris i
worked for him he was my editor on the
spectator you talk about um wanting to
use stunt women you talk about the
importance of choreographing fights on
stage as well look what just happened
last
month with the gun
i'd work with guns in films and every
single time that i don't like guns i've
been given a gun i said to the prop man
i said please open it up in front of me
so i can see inside to see that there's
nothing in it can you even imagine what
alec baldwin has been going through
since this has happened i can't even
imagine it must be hell just because
it's cop 26 at the moment uh you played
the ex-wife of an oil uh tycoon on
dynasty of course
would that have worked if he was doing
wind farms what do we
think of the uh
i don't think so life has moved on
could celebrities do with perhaps uh in
all seriousness cutting down the the
private jets and what have you not just
celebrities did you see the amount of
cars that joe biden had i mean i can't i
was watching sky news of course and i i
counted at least 10 cars you see i'm
very opinionated
but we love you for it thank you so much
for talking thank you katie
she's a legend so jealous of katie now
you may have thought it only happened in
the movies but now
it's all for real nasa has introduced
the first planetary defense test mission
a spacecraft it plans to launch later
this month on a mission to crash
into an asteroid
calling it the dart the goal is to
determine whether the impact of the
spacecraft will change the asteroids
course now the asteroid in question is
didymus and it's moon dimorphous now
though neither poses a threat to the
earth it is a useful test according to
nasa best done
before the real thing happens
good point
okay that's a look at the weather for
you
and it today looks mainly dry but there
are going to be unsettled conditions
coming in tomorrow although it will be
milder so it's chilly out there today
widespread frost across england and
wales especially in the south cloud in
the north and west will become more
extensive through the morning but the
southeast of england will hold on to the
sunshine most places dry but the west
will see some outbreaks of light rain or
drizzle mainly on the coasts
east anglia and the southeast will be
rather cold again i'm afraid to tell you
but maybe the temperatures will go up a
little bit on yesterday we'll come in an
hour
[Music]